welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka spoiling King
and this video will be breaking down the
third episode of The Outsider the new
HBO show has a hell of a lot to unpack
from it and the introduction of Holly
Gibney brings a lot with it throughout
this video we'll be breaking down the
ins and outs of the episode things you
may have missed
as well as what could be happening in
the future there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
potentially ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now we will
be talking about certain elements of the
book so if you don't want to know
anything at all then it's probably best
to go hide in a barn until this video is
over though the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
outsider episode 3 opens in the barn
from last week with a GBI
investigating the clothes that were
found there the GBI stands for the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation and the
nature of the crime scene has clearly
caught their attention they believed
that the clothes belonged to Terry
Maitland who even in death is still
suspected of murder and it's likely that
they think this is where he stashed his
bloody clothes as they were never found
the black ooze like substance is sunken
into them and completely stiffened the
attire making a sock so hard you can
snap it I'll tell you what it took me
back to my teenage years that did the
police snag bag and tag the evidence but
it doesn't seem like they really know
what's going on I'm proud of the
farmhand for calling this in and though
we did suspect last week that the
outsider would be lying low here it
doesn't look like he's gonna have the
opportunity to rejoin officer Jack
Hoskins who shows up late and half-cut
and spots the outsider moving about the
area something grazes the back of his
neck and this becomes their first
meeting King didn't really bring the
supernatural elements in the book till
quite near the end but here they are
setting it up very early in the
storyline the outsider ended up working
with Jack to bring our protagonist Ralph
Anderson down but yeah they could be
taking a slightly different turn with it
which I'll get into further in the
breakdown
as for Anderson himself even though he's
only the case is clearly getting to him
when visiting his son's grave he notices
too for the Petersons and we are
reminded that they lost two children in
the wake of last week's episodes there's
also an open one which could signify
that father Pearson also tried to commit
suicide and the grave diggers are just
being pre-emptive you have to be
economic in these times I guess I don't
know if that's definitely the case but
with it being unmarked that's how I took
it maybe father Peterson did go through
with it and this could be signifying
that the character died in hospital we
don't know for definite but yeah those
are just the theories floating about at
the moment you also join a prisoner
reading a book called lost in the maze
this could either refer to the book on
Isis by Gary William Ramsey or it could
also be a nod to lost in the maze
finding myself by ebloom personally I
think it's the latter as that is a
self-help book we later learn in the
episode that this character is in prison
for the murder of two sisters and that
this crime was likely committed by the
outsider who framed him much in the same
way that he framed maitland finding
myself could mean that he believed he
could have carried out the crime and
just not remembered it and yeah he's
trying to find himself he is literally
trying to find himself because the
killer looked exactly like him and yeah
this book is a nice little nod to that
anyway he's in trouble and people are
willing to stick knives in their legs in
order to get him
however he kills himself at the end
possibly because he also believes he's a
monster and there's unable to reconcile
with what he thinks he did those are
just that theories but it shows you how
much the outsider gets in your head
which this episode slowly sets up
detective sob low meets with Anderson to
discuss what they found in the barn and
the closest match to Maitland they can
make is that there was a belt buckle
layer that the suspect was seen wearing
and CCTV footage there were also prints
located on the buckle which are so faint
that they could belong to a nine year
old juxtaposing this are the same prints
but they appear to be that of a younger
person meaning that whatever made them
was young one moment and old the next
door vice versa there's also a black
substance that was found there which is
a calling card of the outsider and this
was seen last week in the Maitland's
home
that the antagonist had been there he
later returns there to tell Jessa to
pass something on for him and having
been discovered in the barn
this shadow has had to flee back to
their home this teases that the great
evil behind this all has been around for
almost a century and can also take on
the appearance of others Anderson is
eventually led to Hawley Gibney and she
becomes attached to the case Hawley
Gibney is recurring character and Kings
work and she not only appeared in The
Outsider but also the bill hodges
trilogy which is comprised of mr.
Mercedes Finders Keepers and and watch
as forgive me she has an almost
encyclopedic knowledge of pretty much
everything and she sees this as both a
gift and a curse holly has OCD a
photographic memory sensory processing
disorder a fear of flying and is on the
spectrum however she's also blessed with
the aforementioned knowledge and is
highly observant we also learn a lot
about Andersen in the episode namely
that he took the death of his child
badly and that he can handle himself in
a fight
Halle meets with them and decides to
work with him and she pours over the
case files and really seems to be the
big brain that they need on the case to
get to the bottom of it Holly says that
whoever the searching for sounds like a
doppelganger an identical double that
looked exactly like Maitland this ties
into what the outsider really is and
we're going to be talking about what's
actually going on so if you don't want
anything ruined then I definitely
suggest that you turn off now be still
here gray okay so the outsider is
actually a vampire that is able to take
on the appearance of others through
their DNA in Episode two the Maitland's
mentioned to anderson that when teri was
visiting his father he got it cut and
this is how the villain was able to take
on his appearance the outsider tracked
them across the country and then came to
the area and began masquerading as
Maitland in order to frame him when he
came face to face with Jack and
scratched him I believe that he took on
his appearance and this is given weight
by geser
when discussing the character she says
that the first time he look like daddy
but the second time he only did a little
bit like someone had tried to erase his
face Jessa later adds that he looked
inky which is lip service to the black
goo like substance which showed here
that he was beginning to deteriorate she
says that he was built better than a
father was and this could show that he
is taking on the appearance of Jack Jack
is clearly being tormented by the
outsider and I think he will be forced
to work with him in the book Jack
actually has cancer and the outsider
says that he will cure him in exchange
for Jack killing Anderson however in the
show I think that the outsider has
actually given Jack cancer and is
tormenting him over it this is
exemplified by Jack saying make it stop
several times in the episode and I
believe the mark on his neck will begin
spreading we see at the end of the
episode that the rash is getting a lot
worse and it could be turning cancerous
as for Holly she travels around several
key locations of the case trying to get
to the bottom of what's going on the
CCTV for where the van was stolen no
longer exists a creepy guy works there
she's unable to visit Terry's dad as she
isn't family but in a hotel room on a
computer she finds his story about a
search for two missing sisters she
discovers that a local hospital worker
is in custody for the slaying and this
ties back to the prisoner and the seller
we've seen throughout the episode and it
caught on Terry's hand that he gained
there the pieces are now all falling
into place and we can sort of build a
timeline from this we know that the
outside had traveled to the hospital
took on the nurses appearance and
carried out the murders the sisters that
turned up dead did go missing for a
while so this would give him some leeway
to operate in the area during his work
at the hospital the outsider knew that
he was living on borrowed time and
needed a new identity he cut Terry and
then followed the Maitland's
cross-country and ended up kick-starting
the story at the show centers around we
see the prisoner kill himself and then
the episode ends with Jack saying
whatever you need me to do with a huge
rash on the back of his neck taking a
lot of focus as we said earlier I
believe that he has cancer now and that
the outsider is going to be using him as
a pawn to take down Anderson Anderson
clearly isn't backing down from the
investigation even after a warning from
the outsider and he will likely send
Jack to kill him in exchange for ending
the torment and removing that thing on
the back of his neck either way I'm
really enjoying the show and I'm
surprised at how much they're putting in
place this early on the book drag things
out quite a lot but this seems to be
setting up so much in the preview next
week
like we will learn more of the ins and
outs of the hospital and the nurse and
through maintenance father we will
discover how the outsider taunted him it
is possible that the outsider took on
his appearance and this could explain
the 90 year old fingerprint and why the
nurses think that he has dementia the
outsider corn copy memories and nurse if
he was asked questions by the nurses you
would just sort of give a a very
rambling sort of answer and this might
just make them think that he has
dementia and can't remember anything we
do see in the preview that he does seem
quite cognitive so yeah that's just sort
of my theory for at the moment we will
also likely finally uncover exactly what
the outsider is as Holly's going to be
visiting someone who seems to know about
the creature overall I am hooked on the
show at the moment and I love watching
the slow-burn series slowly set things
in place I'm so glad the show is putting
it all together early on as this was a
big criticism that I had with a book
it's really working out well oh and I've
loved the first three episodes and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the outsider and what you think will
be happening in the future if you read
the source material let me know how you
think it compares and make sure you
check out a full breakdown of everything
we know so far about the Batman which is
going to be linked at the end you can
support the show by subscribing to us on
patreon and if you want to come chat to
us after the video you can join a
discord server in the description below
or follow us on twitter at definition
whitey i also just want to let you know
we're giving away a free copy of dr.
sleep to one random subscriber will you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the outside or in the comment section
below
the one is gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February in this that'll be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]